what's going on guys welcome back to the
rumor roundup show
this is our show where we run over all
the rumors that have been going on for
the whole week in case you missed them
and first things first at the time that
we're recording this video which is june
24th
a new trailer for shang chi is coming
out tonight now
this trailer is going to be a little bit
different from the first one that we saw
the first one largely focused on chiang
chi which is cool
this one is supposed to focus more on
the mandarin showing us
mandarin fight scenes different things
like that and i got to be honest with
you guys
i am hyped one of the things i'm really
hoping for in the shanghai movie
is that we see it open up with sir ben
kingsley being brought before the
mandarin to kind of wrap
up to that little mini film that we got
and then ultimately he's like why are
you using my name ben kinsey's like i
mean it was just an act and then he just
takes him in the back and executes him
or something i don't know
maybe just throw him in a prison i mean
i don't see him die i just want to see
it like
wrap into what was going on with like
the little sir ben kingsley mini movie i
think he probably would kill him though
the mandarin strikes me as a person that
would probably execute a person
who was using his name like that it just
seems like something he would do
but the trailer i'm really hoping is
going to be awesome i mean the
soundtrack to the first trailer was
amazing
that song was lit and i'm really hoping
the second trailer is gonna be much
the same way i think it'll be like
wonder woman where it's basically just
the same song maybe a little bit of a
different version of it or maybe the
same version
maybe a different song i don't know but
ultimately it's gonna be cool
i gotta say i'm loving seeing shang chi
he's not really the most powerful
character in marvel comics
but he's one of these characters with a
really really interesting backstory
depending on how you approach it and
some of the roles he's had over the
years of marvel comics have been really
really cool he was part of heroes for
hire
he was in jonathan hickman's avengers
the new avengers and gained the power to
basically duplicate himself he taught
spider-man his own martial arts style
called the way of the spider this guy
is kind of like one of the go-to guys
when it comes to like fighting styles
and so on he's a really cool character
so i'm very excited to see
what this new trailer is going to give
us now moving away from the marvel
cinematic universe for a quick second
the steam
summer sale is on yes it is it actually
started i think
yesterday but for those of you guys who
aren't familiar with this steam is
basically the main gaming platform for
pc gaming i mean you have origin you
have a few others everything like that
but steam is the one that pretty much
everybody uses
and they have these summer sales that go
on every year which in recent years have
kind of sucked they used to be
awesome but the steam summer sale is
awesome i'm excited to see that it's
here and i gotta go through and peruse a
whole bunch of different games so i'm
gonna post my steam code
up here on the youtube video find me on
steam send me your friend request and
we'll play some multiplayer games
together
but continuing on with this bit of a
gaming trend for those of you guys who
love killer instinct and i have loved
killer instinct ever since the game
first came out
way back in the day according to phil
spencer the head of the microsoft xbox
division we are not getting a new
version anytime
soon and i feel like a lot of you guys
are going to be really disappointed by
that
i know i am killer instinct is one of
those classic fighting games if you guys
aren't really familiar with killer
instinct that was one of those games
that was predicated on the success of
classic fighting games like mortal
kombat street fighter which have long
since had a role
in the gaming community but killer
instinct was very similar to that it was
very very
cool when it first came out and it has a
huge
following right the people who are
followers of it are die hard right they
are they are
extreme there are tournaments held on
this thing i mean killer instinct has a
big market out there
and it's going to be disappointing to
know that we're not going to get a new
one but phil spencer kind of followed up
to that and said don't worry guys
i know you want one we're going to make
sure the one that we get you the new one
is going to be a great one so i am
excited to see what they come out with
and to be honest
i'm not really against the idea that
microsoft and them are like we want to
kind of take our time and make sure we
develop one that's really really good
because if they make one that's bad fans
are gonna be pissed
they're gonna have to deal with all that
backlash on social media and i
for one would not want to be a party to
that but circling back into our movie
news for a quick second
black widow and i gotta be honest i feel
kind of bad about the black widow news
we'll talk about why here in a second
but black widow has kind of revealed and
it's really been a talking point for
quite some time so i don't really know
how new this
is but they basically revealed that the
whole budapest plot thing the concept
that was brought up some time ago
between black widow and hawkeye
is actually going to be a major point in
the movie i feel like nobody cares when
black widow news comes out
outside of that video that we did where
it was revealed that black widow would
likely end up lifting thor's hammer we
would see that in the what if series
nobody really seems to care about the
black widow movie i feel like a lot of
that's because they killed her off
so why would anybody care about seeing a
movie about a character they killed off
it's not like we're gonna get a
continuation of it
i feel like that was a huge mistake if
they were gonna release a solo film that
was focused on natasha romanov then they
should have done it
when she was alive they should have done
that as like one of the other movies in
the the beginning of the marvel phases
as opposed to releasing the movie about
a character who's dead because i think
one of the things that drives a lot of
us when it comes to seeing movies about
characters in the mcu is the potential
of seeing them later right so we want to
know what their backstory is so we can
kind of get that stuff done and out of
the way and then look for like easter
eggs and little things like that
in the movie for stuff that'll appear
later on you know little things along
those lines but they're literally
they killed her character why would we
care if they released a solo movie
why would it matter to us right so i
don't know let me know what you guys
think down in the comments whether or
not you care about the black widow film
because i know some people are going to
say yes but i feel like a lot of people
are going to be like
not really i feel like that's going to
be most people's reaction so let me know
in the comments
i'm curious what your all's thoughts are
but jumping back into gaming for a
second if you guys notice we're kind of
going back and forth between gaming and
movies one of the things we want to do
here with the rumor roundup is we want
to expand it beyond someone just
covering news and rumors regarding to
comic book movies and tv shows we want
to include stuff like gaming and things
like that because
you guys much like me are huge fans of
that stuff and i think it'd be kind of
cool to include those little tidbits in
here but
the 30th anniversary of sonic the
hedgehog was this week specifically on
the 23rd
and so mojang the creators of minecraft
helped to celebrate the 30th anniversary
of sonic the hedgehog by introducing
skins and adding some theme songs that
were based on the original sonic game
i personally never really played the
first sonic i mean i did but i never
played it in the same amount of time
that i played like sonic 2.
sonic 2 was my game right that was my
sonic game sonic and knuckles
was okay i thought it was all right it
was cool that you could take the sonic
and knuckles cartridge
and plug the other sonic games into it
and then have knuckles and other sonic
games
that was cool but sonic 2 that was my
game sonic 3 was awesome but only
because it had the music from the icecap
zone
do you guys know what i'm talking about
you guys know exactly what i'm talking
about but we thought it was just a cool
little bit of news to drop here right
that
sonic is so world renowned that other
games
are celebrating the anniversary of one
of the most significant side scrollers
in the history of the video gaming
industry
by doing their own little tributes
that's cool i love that it's one of the
great things about the gaming community
is everything seems to be so tight-knit
among developers because a lot of the
people who develop these games that
exist now
started playing games like sonic the
hedgehog and street fighter and mortal
kombat and super mario
so it's cool to see that they're kind of
paying homage to the things that got
them
into the genre that they're in by
putting little easter eggs and little
moments and celebrations and so on and
so forth but our final little bit of
news here for the rumor roundup this
week comes in the form of news that we
got
about spider-woman yes the project that
is largely being headed up by olivia
wilde i've been a fan of olivia wilde
ever since the tv show house
but what we found out here is that the
spider woman movie is actually going to
focus on jessica
drew jessica drew is the original spider
woman she appeared back in 1977 in
marvel spotlight number 32.
do you guys remember that discussion
that we did we were talking about marvel
feature how marvel would release
these comics that had a whole bunch of
different stories and they did it for
the purpose of just finding out what
characters or teams people would like
marvel spotlight was basically the exact
same way
so jessica drew makes her appearance
there she turns out to be popular
because honestly back in the 1970s
anything related to spider-man would be
popular
and the following year in 1978 she got
her own title called spider woman number
one by marv wolfman
the origin there was a little wonky
basically what happened is she had
suffered from uranium poisoning so she
received an injection
that featured spider-man blood all that
happened at mount wondagor which some of
you guys might know is the home of the
high evolutionary eventually she was put
in a kind of chamber that would
basically accelerate the entire process
she came out a few decades later she was
still basically 17 years old
then went forward as spider woman in
2006 that was changed by brian michael
bendis with spider woman origins
and we basically had this still kind of
wonky origin where her mom
was basically blasted with a laser while
she was pregnant with jessica drew and
it contained
energies belonging to different spiders
and that's how she ended up gaining or
gaining her abilities honestly
the origin stories of jessica drew have
never really made any sense but for
those of you guys who are curious about
her character if you want to read about
jessica drew
go read new avengers by brian michael
bendis it's a fantastic
place to start because it's basically
when they brought her back
her comic just kind of dropped off in
popularity she was eventually replaced
by the second spider woman somebody
named julia carpenter
who actually debuted during secret wars
back in 1984
but it's one of these things where she's
kind of a character that's been around
for a long long time
and depending on who you're talking to
there's huge fans there's folks who
don't really care i care about jessica
drew
but only if the story is interesting so
that's kind of my take on things
but it is cool that we're going to see
her in a movie as far as i'm aware and i
can't speak to this as an absolute i
think it's still a little murky as to
whether or not it's actually going to be
part of the marvel cinematic universe
and if it's not going to be part of the
mcu that's kind of interesting because
we know that sony is sort of working
alongside the mcu
and presumably when kevin feige told us
that the marvel cinematic universe was
going to become its own multiverse
that sony's whole movies right venom and
all that kind of stuff that's not
directly tied in the mcu will just kind
of exist as an alternate reality out
there in this grand multiverse
and maybe we'll see it from time to time
at this point it's still a little fuzzy
exactly how all this stuff works right
michael morbius is appearing or at least
seems to appear in the marvel cinematic
universe because we saw that vulture
was in the film so that's gonna be a
little weird right little
tributes to spider-man being called a
killer presumably after he had quote
unquote
murdered mysterio so it's a little murky
in terms of how all this stuff ties
together honestly we won't really know
until we probably get a few movies into
it and then we kind of get a good idea
of how it all just kind of comes
together and it's organized and so on
but regardless that's this week's
episode of the rumor roundup thank you
guys for watching leave a comment down
below if there's any particular news
that we missed that you want us to cover
and we will catch you all later peace